the jurogan experience how i got
introduced to you i
had heard about reservoir dogs but the
first film i saw was pulp fiction
and i saw pulp fiction with this girl
that i was dating when i first
moved to los angeles and i remember
being in man's chinese theater
watching this yeah and for me it was
like this crazy
change in my life that was in the first
that was in the first few weeks of it
opening yeah because that's where it
opened
yeah crazy change in my life moving to
los angeles and then seeing this film
and then i remember very clearly like at
the end of the film
like even in the middle of the film
going this is the craziest [ __ ] movie
i've ever seen in my life
and this scene it symbolized to me like
the world was changing like everything
was changing
it was so wild and so crazy it was a
film not
it was unlike anything i'd ever seen
before what all the the different
timelines how you interwove everything
together
but the violence and the chaos and the
humor
of all of it like people walked out of
that movie theater [ __ ] up yeah
and i remember thinking like wow like
the the world is different
like sometimes you'll see a work of art
or something
and you'll say that thing just changed
everything it just
it was so wild that it it it influenced
so many other films afterwards they
tried to be
like a pulp fiction movie are they
trying to be wild well people would ask
me about that and they go hey did that
really bug you
when there was a period of it seemed
like five years
in the 90s where like every crime film
kind of had this like ironic
bit and and they talked about tv shows
and played
music in a weird way yeah and everybody
was a smart ass
um and they asked me like well
does that did that bother you and i go
well no it doesn't bother me one i don't
think any of them are as good as mine so
it just makes mine look better and
better and
my dialogue looked better and better but
you know one of my favorite directors
is sergio leone and i always considered
i was doing
to traditional gangster films like you
know scorsese
kind of goodfella kind of movies what he
was doing
to traditional westerns when he did his
spaghetti westerns
so then the fact that mine hit and now
the fact that i've it
not it wasn't that they were just trying
to do pulp fiction or reservoir dogs
they were trying to exist in the same
subgenre
of crime film that i had created which
is what all the other spaghetti westerns
that came after leone's
had done so the fact that it wasn't they
were doing just reservoir dogs or pulp
fiction
rip-offs uh i'd created a sub-genre
in gangster films that did not exist
before and they were trying to fill
that sub genre and that was [ __ ]
awesome
[Laughter]
that's got to be a wild feeling it was
great i understand
genre i had affected gangster i mean by
that point to do kind of a scorsese kind
of thing was like
almost passe yeah well you brought back
john travolta yeah uh-huh which is
pretty wild too
well i remember even asking somebody i
go uh okay well people say tarantino
asked what do they mean and there was a
guy i knew he was a he's like a film
analyst his name dave scow
and he goes well
okay just to give you an idea it's like
okay so in bad boys or
yeah i think maybe no it's like bad boys
like well again bad boys okay you have a
couple of henchmen working for the bad
guy and they're sitting in their car
and all of a sudden they have a
conversation about
an i love lucy episode okay that
wouldn't have happened without you
yeah it's true yeah
yeah well what is that from i mean where
have you had this uh this flair for
references
and then this uh this way of layering
that just comes from being gen x man i
mean that was that was the whole thing
about
like uh about that generation is the
idea that
um okay in the okay the generation
before us that like lived through the
60s they had the 60s they had the
accoutrement of the 60s they had all
that 60s music
um and they looked down on the
generation that grew up in the 60s
in the 70s so like you didn't have any
of that [ __ ] you didn't have the music
that we had
well maybe we didn't have the music you
had we had our music
but what we did have is we had
television we had the saturday morning
cartoons that we dug
we had schoolhouse rock we had all the
tv shows we liked we had speed racer
we had all these kind of things and they
meant something to us
and you know um
kids back then who if their parents
didn't let them watch tv at a certain
point
well the parents might have actually had
like the best intentions but they were
actually robbing
their children of the pop cultural
glue that's going to tie them to their
generation when they get older
and so you know we had the abc movies of
the week i mean we just yeah we had all
that stuff and we had
[ __ ] great movies if you were going
out and seeing the movies in new
hollywood
we had all that and so um
when we got older it was about talking
about that stuff that was
that was what was worth talking about
and then to actually have characters in
the movie talk about that that was
making them sound realistic and to be
specific about it
remember that old sitcom no no no talk
about no you mean you mean alice okay
talk about you talk about mel and alice
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience